next up if you're out there dating
and i know you can relate to this i
certainly can getting ghosted is kind of
the worst when someone goes poof on you
especially after you've been connecting
yeah that's when you go
okay it's maybe it's ghosted but it
should be called am i going crazy
exactly um so you're wondering what the
heck went wrong our next guest went
viral for trying to find out
after a guy ghosted her she sent him a
thorough questionnaire to get to the
bottom of it yes she did i am so excited
shanna falk tell us teach us welcome
shannon hi chef thank you hi everyone
thank you so much thank you thank you
for coming on the show
what inspired you to create and send
this exit interview to the guy who goes
to do so i recently changed jobs and in
corporate america once you leave a job
you typically go through an exit
interview and not far after that
happened i got ghosted and i said you
know what let's do something about this
let's call him out on his action so i
had gotten ghosted and i we have that
kind of comedy back and forth that i
thought it would be funny to send him
some funny questions but really just to
call him out on his behavior because
it's not cool it's really not cool
and maybe learn something correct yeah
what was your mental strategy going into
this as well and what advice do you have
for anyone who might want to attempt
this
yeah so i went into it with an open mind
knowing that one he may not respond and
i already got my answer when he ghosted
me so that was that was my first initial
reaction i already got my answer when he
stopped texting me um i know my
self-worth my self-confidence is better
than that so i knew i wasn't going to
get anything out of it
thank you
i love that
curious what kind of questions did you
put on the questionnaire like
how'd you start that's the good
questions
just light-hearted questions um one
really just being able for him to be
able to self-reflect on some things just
calling him out uh one how good looking
am i
oh my god
my personality but they really weren't
questions about me it was more for him
to self-reflect on the actions uh that
he what else give us the results
like where'd you go
yeah yeah um i did i said well i asked
why he ghosted me um and really just the
multiple choice questions were just hey
this is gonna be funny either way for me
um so yeah so there's there's some funny
questions in there but rating my
personality rating my looks which i
don't care what he said either way yeah
um and then um yeah just you know why he
ghosted me what happened so you sent
these questions and then we have to know
did he write back
he did he did
[Applause]
tell me every what did he say yes so he
initially you know gave me great
responses but the big thing was is
things were moving too fast for him the
connection was really strong between us
which is also why i kind of sent this to
him what went wrong there was no
defining moment um as to why he goes to
me we weren't talking about anything
specific when it happened so um he was
he was open to let me know that it was
just moving too fast for him and that he
was the one in the wrong so
i'm glad he took responsibility for it i
mean like you know if i think anybody
that's ghosted somebody it's usually has
to do with that person like they're not
ready to be in a relationship and at
least he owned those feelings but you
know what women how is it for men
because women love closure oh yeah it's
like i almost don't care what the answer
is i would just prefer the answer
um so how has everybody respond to this
because this has gone bananas it's viral
everybody's talking about it like a
million views on tick tock thousands of
responses what are people saying yeah
yeah
it just really kind of built a community
where
people were open and honest about hey
this happened to me really made me
realize that i want to get back to
dating in the real world i hate the apps
i'm over them there's just so much
missed in the apps so i've been working
on creating a social group here in
nashville for singles just to meet out
in public um get back out into the world
and uh and and get off the apps there's
so much missed on the apps of
personality and um they can be pretty
shallow at times so working on getting
that started shanna i bet the company
that lost you is really bummed out right
now you are so smart yeah
i bet the man that lost you is pretty
bummed out too i know you are like the
biggest catch personally and
professionally do you mind if we circle
back with you again i'd like to catch up
with you again
i would love that
[Music]
you